tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo nuovi
tool finalmente siamo sulla nuova season
di ball guys dopo 6.000 anni avevo fatto
la live dove l'abbiamo provata già le
nuove mappe ma questo è il primo video
dedicate video di fare una bella partita
dove ovviamente prenderò le scoppole
quando devo fare cose fatte bene
speriamo ragazzi in partire subito con
una mappa nuova invece di quelle vecchie
perché partiamo subito con due perfetta
questa questa nuovissima riuscita ieri
queste gate crescita ormai ragazzi però
non so se lo sapete ve lo dico io
le mappe nuove per adesso perché poi
durante la season e metteranno di altre
sono esattamente 4
non mi ricordo assolutamente i nomi e
speriamo insomma che ne mettono poi
anche altre però che questo video escano
poi soprattutto perché si non ti togli
però io parto sempre da fatto sempre
dietro al tizio fermo perché mi sembra
un classico ormai un classico va bene
ragazzi allora che seguirà live
l'altro giorno sa che ho comprato la
nuova skin leggendaria la duchessa che
si vedeva in basso a destra non la
ricompro anche su playstation perché mi
fa anche abbastanza un po cagare dove si
dice però è valcava niente di minaccioso
eliminato non soli minato attenzione va
bene va bene sta facendo aspetto che su
playstation 4 aumentano le stime nuove
perché troppo ci ha sicuramente qualche
leggendaria stile medievale perché
questo assillo ragazza in stile
medievale vediamo insomma ragazzi il
rollout lo odio quindi la saltiamo che
ho già vinto quanto tempo per madonna ma
la notte è diventata non lo so è lenta
come la morte un fastidio rivolta
sarebbe bella ne vedete che tra l'altro
nelle anteprime le vedete già le mappe
nuove però vorrei giocarle
eccola qua si legge perfetto meno male
frase l'ho chiamata perché sono chiusi
legends come lo spiego tipo praticamente
è come spiego regalo è come un cross e
non mi muovo non c'è né un genio sono un
genio aob si legge
meno male recuperato subito la mia
cacciata iniziale scusante per prima
gioco e poi parlo però la vedo adesso e
molto chic
quindi mi ritengo abbastanza bravo che
li più appena fianco e odioso cinesi
ragazzi e la mappa dovete vita a tim
entrare investì certi clown si legge non
solo di fare da solo
e la cosa veramente infame e che bisogna
spostare sti cosi questa è la feature
più bella perché molti risposta e poi li
sfrutta un altro che uno si fa le culo
ascoltare ste cose poi uno santa nel
cerchio quindi è molto e molto infame
come mappe molto in fare attenzione
norme numero minardo l'ordinario brutta
schifosa laida di una duchessa maledetta
te la tua skin porco demonio eccolo
eccolo volevi funzionale maledetto
schifoso maledetto 22 marzo
no no cosa aveva un c'è più un cerchio a
okaka mia mamma mia
però avrei mai voluto dire ho vinto
perché genova è convinto poi in un
vicolo hanno raggiunto il basso sinistra
anche si cosi ti prego di personalizzare
il personaggio di questo si chiama sera
brella ci starebbe bene un costume da
richiesta come però spesso ragazzina
book si legge la migliore del nuove
mappe se posso permettermi
no non è vero la seconda migliore la
migliore è quella iniziale con la con le
asce non è ancora comparsa magari nel
prossimo round c'è tanto vogliamo
vincere questo al tra l'altro hanno
cambiato delle cosine nelle altre mappe
che avete dei cosiddetti quindi pto
adesso ragazzi ci sono dei pattern nuovi
sulle piattaforme allora prima a
piattaforme perfetto sempre bene sono
contento che la mia gli ho costruito
troppo e sempre all'inferno e buono
buono buono buono buono buono buono lo
zio
provaci e con la destra con la testa
sicuro avrò novità che vivo io
regolarista sia equa eccola proprio lui
primo no non mi ha dato il primo sono in
atto primo anno mandato prima avevi
sempre allora come finale non c'è niente
di nuovo tramite il jack showdown perché
job show down hanno modificato la
velocità delle lancette è inoltre hanno
verificato i colori però la mappa viene
sempre quella quindi vediamo giorgio
dame perfetto sto per dire o quello
extra con la grandezza non mi sarebbe
piaciuto fare visto che non vuol modi
ragazzi uguale sul monte mi è rimasto
uguale io sono fra spiego mi facevo dei
ragazzi allora già show down è cambiata
la velocità delle lancette proprio c'è
adesso partono più veloci prima non era
così veloce subito era
molto violente gabbiani partner promesso
le coroncine sui batteri molto bello
vediamo se effettivamente posso provare
a vincere la nuova lancio dow sembra
anche per un suo ragazzi a vederlo
sembra che non sia cambiato tanto ma vi
assicuro che per una persona come me che
gioca un sacco di tempo a folgaria
io vedo la differenza del partire con le
lancette più veloci la vedo proprio
vi giuro che mi fa strano però comunque
la mappa è quella quindi non è che dice
è cambiato molto ok a seccare vola blu
di sono a posto io
ecco perfetta la speriamo in un casa
proprio pensa speleologica dalla sua
avrà niente è caduto lui quindi a posto
no ragazzi sta la vedo brutta perché
questi qua sono un po infami secondo me
c'è chiara skin del ninja è sempre i fan
non è il niger del tennista è sempre
infame sono indeciso se grabar non meno
raga perché se d g e poi perdo faccio la
figura del pirla beni non voglio
gravarli però forse mi vedrò costretto a
farlo non lo so dipende come si metterà
la situazione ragazzi a un grappino
tattico porca vacca
se avete passato le cuffie e perché già
per ora scritto sopra perché sennò vi ha
storditi meno male ragazzi perché avrei
voluto un sacco gravarli a un certo dopo
il salto gli avrei grappa ti meno male
che non siamo non ho dovuto ricorrere
alle maniere forti meno ma le ragazze
la partenza ragazza è stata top quindi
per adesso per adesso mi sento
abbastanza fortunato superiore alla
doppia vittoria tanto ragazzi hanno
fissato una roba adesso non si capisce
chi vuole la porta ad affondare alla
fine stipe senti maledetti l'hanno tolto
era l'unica sentenza avevo nella vita la
porta finale di lorrach adesso mondo di
quello da mentre dammi un 2
dammi un sua sorella fu proprio lui va
dai ragazzi allora speriamo di una tappa
nuova parco lemonia
ho fatto solo così densi cioè se
vendiamo silenzi headline klein
va beh va beh non so se avete notato sta
roba che la faccio io
hanno saturato di bestia i colori ci i
colori sono satura tissi mi sa purissime
saturati per scorsi un cuscino dopo
penso alla grammatica prima pensiamo al
cuscino paola perfetto
ottima la partenza la gara 3 mamma mia
ma che ciò oggi allora porca vacca e
fammi salire o che a posto tanto la
gente come scaletta non ha mai non ha
mai avuto un senso nel mio pensiero ma
ci sta poi sta funzionando
oddio arrivò primo togliti togliti è
arrivato prima a caso totalmente a caso
va bene potrebbe anche seminari in 14
oppure paul bowles oppure no se hace
campo devi essere dispari noti gli spari
essere 5 10 15 quindi potrebbe essere
paul polly potrebbe essere una finale
anche
exa con uno per del genere oppure
potrebbe dal polo appunto formò la rai
ha voglia un gioco pulito non fate gli
scarsi per l'amore di gesù ti prego
prova a spingere la catena degli
avversari perfetto consegnato autogol
perfetto questo è fatta rago che si sono
l'ici nicchia come non dico più niente o
di lara di mandare fai schifo ma alle
ditte ma perché voi che dite perchè mi
devono devono far alterare i compagni
giocate
ci sono riusciti a ragazzi non devo
pagarla lavori e la palla vedevo parola
loro puntata di la di la sete in 12 ma
cosa farà veramente a fate ridere no no
no no no no no no no no no no vado tanto
e mena voti gente che ci sono non in
difesa una sorgente bravi scholes no no
no ragazzi non fate i seri ma veramente
abbia preso gol ma qualcuno in difesa
c'è nonno di gioco
il tuo tv dei motoneuroni c day the
pensanti ma chi minchia devo avere in
squadra nuova ragazzi imbarazzante no no
no non mi rifiuto visto rifiutando con
questa perché se la perdiamo nuovo
veramente no nuova gara dai ragazzi dai
ragazzi siamo su scherzi a parte dai
ragazzi veramente
ma fate ridere ma siete ridicoli ma
perché li mettono in squadra delle
scimmie
i ragazzi spero che viene vi sia
piaciuto avere una vittoria oggi è
arrivata peccato per i miei con per
carità non si insultano i compagni di
squadra per comunque siamo sportivi però
basta bravi gli sia piaciuto ragazzi
lasciato il momento mi piace il sedile è
uscita solo un si legge una volta però
confido nei prossimi episodi per far
vedere un politi della pecorella season
2 sfondare le leggi il video e noi come
sempre ci vediamo ad un prossimo vita
della ragazza
[Musica]